okay hi everyone so my name is Daniel
ruse I am one of the cofounders of newer
DOM a small FinTech but before that I
worked in the finance industry at banks
and system vendors for about 20 years
mainly using Python and that's the
reason for this talk I've seen Python
used for like a lot of interesting
things really good opportunities for
jobs really good opportunities to sell
products to big companies with a lot of
cash a lot of this is not super well
known but the finance industry can be a
bit complex and it can also be a bit
secretive as will get you so goal today
is to do a deep dive into this vertical
so leaving machine learning behind a bit
and instead of focusing on Finance but
how python is use there hopefully you'll
learn something interesting and maybe
come away with something that's useful
personally to you at the end a demo if
there's time to do some kind of trading
strategies first of all finance what is
it very briefly you can think of it as
three things banking everything with
money loans making payments asset
management everything about making money
grow but this is also like a routing
function it's a magic that you have some
money left over you put it into your
account somewhere it goes into fund and
suddenly a brick factory in New Delhi
can buy a machine make more bricks make
more money so like a global routing
function insurance all about risks
pricing risk spreading them around
essential for like every person and also
businesses okay then there's this guy
like all businesses when there's money
involved people get greedy
so financed there are elements there's
been scandals crashes but if we step
away from that finance is essentially
infrastructure for our society and for
like making things work it's the first
thing I'd like to highlight is
- is big it's bigger than most people
think both in terms of size and impact
let's get concrete this scary diagram is
a map of all the 500 biggest rocks in
the US the size of the squares is like
the market cap of the company how big
they are so you can see Google Microsoft
Amazon Apple like the really big blobs
this port here about 20% that's the
finance industry this port basically
deals about moving money around to help
all the other businesses do their jobs
and it's bigger than consumer goods it's
same size as healthcare so when we say
the finance industry it's big just
remember this picture like 20% and then
why should you care well like I
mentioned there's interesting jobs got
some stats from before 12 and 1/2
percent but since the revenues are so
big they're actually quite lucrative
jobs 26% of all corporate profits okay
maybe you don't work in the industry but
you are making a really cool new machine
learning product like your customers a
big part of them are gonna be finance
and they're also customers that have big
budgets for IT recent survey 2018
finance spends 440 billion u.s. dollars
on IT 30% of that count goes in house
rest out house and it's growing finally
the one I mentioned personal finances
like if you're really talented you come
out you work super hard put all your
money in the bank and retire not the
smartest thing if you do the same thing
you work 2% less spend those 2% managing
your money in a good way you could like
maybe double what you retire with so not
doing anything about it is shooting
yourself in the foot
that's just good to be aware of
everybody has to be involved in finance
so you might as well know the rules and
it can be really fun too now okay that
was finance so back to why we're here
Python I'll highlight some areas where
I've seen it used in like interesting
ways
first one trading in risk you've
probably seen these kind of pictures on
the news there's like this big trading
floor at a bank and they're asking about
the economy
these guys are trading commodities FX
currencies etc first thing you might
wonder why do they need like twelve
screens I have no idea I've been there
they don't switch things very well
second thing what are they running there
what it all looks like Excel what are
they doing there what they're running or
usually trading systems and these are
systems that are really complex they're
actually too complex for the bank's to
build themselves so there's a couple of
global vendors that build them these
systems handle like all kind of
calculations huge amounts of data and in
super real time like you know merely
microsecond they are millions of lines
of code ports of you have PhD level math
and they're super expensive can easily
be two thousand US dollars per user per
month and they need to be customizable
so the one I'm super familiar with its
front arena it's built here on Sodor
Malm by about 200 developers originally
Swedish software now US company and back
in 99 they made the decision like we
need to customize this we'll put in Perl
or Python so luckily they went for
Python which was a good long-term bet
and nowadays like brunch of the business
logic is developed by Python this
company has courses where they teach
people in finance how to use Python
thousand plus people certified so more
technically Python embedded in a C++
application lets you combine the raw
speed of like C++ with ability to go to
a new market and then customize how
trade surprised or local workflows
Python code is stored in the database
you can do changes instantly you have a
solid application delivered by vendor
you push new Python code into the
database and things update in real time
now moving to the secretive parts I said
some parts of Finance or not that kind
of well-known you have the hedge funds
and the quants the idea here is to beat
the market and make money so basically
you're saying we're gonna figure out
some mispricing
and we will just make money we will look
at data have a lots of ideas evaluate
them and
make better returns and investing in the
stock market and of course if you know
how to do this you're not going to tell
anybody because if everybody does it you
know there's no money to make and these
are like they invented big data before
there was big data they're all over
machine learning and AI you know exactly
when it was happening and this give me
things like taking you know crazy stuff
like taking aerial photographs counting
cars in parking lots with some kind of
algorithm and trying to figure out if
the store is doing good business before
the report comes out so like really fun
stuff the little picture on the side
here they're like horrible ugly web page
is a company I think second biggest edge
fund they manage a hundred and ten
billion dollars in mat assets like super
sophisticated company and the website
basically says hey we manage money no
email no telephone numbers just an
address to send legal documents so this
is kind of the way it works and then you
can read forums and stuff and figure out
which ones are good which ones are not
and you know what they're hiring for etc
and they just want anecdote their books
hedge funds are fun when you think speed
like Python they will typically use
Python to develop the algorithm then
they'll recode it in C++ to be fast
books Python is slow and I'm going to
like state that regardless of like what
libraries are pi PI or whatever in this
context Python is very slow so the
normal cycle is Python code it is C++ if
it's very time sensitive you code it in
hardware C building FPGA if you're doing
something that's geography so you could
say that we're going to orbit relish
between London or Frankfurt so kind of
try to create the same things in two
places and can't find miss pricings they
will build these networks so the map you
see there of Europe is microwave towers
so light travels faster as microwaves
and an optical fibers so if you can go
from London to Frankfurt faster than
anybody using a normal internet line you
can beat them and you can make like a
profit so it's like three or four
companies that have built the shortest
path they can find of microwave towers
to cut a couple of microseconds
and kind of achieve an advantage there
it sounds like the final level when
you're going to be really really fast
it's not all dark magic though you can
actually try this out so people
discovered crowdsourcing and that
there's a lot of smart people out here
that can apply new techniques to solve
these problems so here's two companies
and they basically work on the same
premise they give you like all the tools
all the data you can write up an
algorithm so maybe you think that if I
buy a stock and Monday and sell it on
Friday it's always going to be
profitable yeah exactly it's a bit
harder than that nowadays then they back
just that and then the magic comes if
your algorithm looks good after all
they're like testing they will run it
with real money and give you like 10% of
the profits
so like zero risk for you if you think
you can beat the stock market by writing
algorithms and it's all in Python by the
way when they needed to do this they
picked Python to like be the language
that they roll out to people to quickly
and easily learn and then build
algorithms so good fun thing to look
look up at home also just a very good
example of how you can use Python to
provide like a high very high level API
like do something with stock trading
switching crack open banking met some
people who mentioned this at lunch
there's getting well-known so regulation
changes the governments have realized
that your data is very valuable and it
shouldn't be locked up at the banks so
we recently got laws called PST to
saying that the banks have to share
their data make them available the API
is then you get new companies coming up
around this one company is tink how many
of heard about Inc ok located over there
by central on for the few of you hadn't
heard about it they make an app that
looks at your spending and basically
tells you you're spending three thousand
kronor some coffee and then you can make
a decision if that's good or bad I guess
they're using Python so I interviewed
them and sure they are there are typical
ml case they use Python what they
appreciate about it is like that it's
easy to get people started great ml
support and that they can also roll out
the same models in production so it's
like develop good deployability
not going to get into that too much it's
basically rehash but good example where
it is happening
last use case I'll pick our own company
startups so when you're stored up you
have to do a lot of things with little
resources and you need to be super
efficient so what we do we're called new
order it's similar to change but is
through your finances so coming from the
banking industry we want to tell people
not to get ripped off so we built an app
that collects all your savings pensions
and investments and then analyzes it
with like professional professional risk
and so you can see like what's happening
what you could do how you could save on
fees so tinker investments but to do
this we needed to like collect a lot of
data clean it up manage complex data
models serve api's and do really fast
risk calculations with a team of six
people in six months so then we reached
for Python and which has really great
support for this straight through
talking to other startups pretty much
every startup I've seen here or advised
in the FinTech industry has Python
elements in it so very very good
penetration on new companies that can
choose a fresher stack at the banks you
still have COBOL etcetera for legacy
reasons but if you're doing a new
company Python is very very much gonna
be in your focus or finance okay those
were like couple use cases they also
give you flavor
now let's step back and summarize so I'm
saying Python it's gonna used everywhere
why is this what's kind of what makes it
interesting first one it's actually like
really really old school it's that
Python is easy to learn I couldn't find
a quote but I believe it's designed to
be easy to read and that a developer
should be able to pick it up in one day
if they know another language it was a
bunch of like early initiatives around
this and since early competition was C++
Java etc which are much more difficult
this was an advantage so back in the
2000s when I was working in front green
and selling this trading system we were
coming into you like big banks and
telling them you're gonna have to learn
this language called Python you've never
heard of it and then we do demos and we
do live coding and they see ok I I
understand what's happening and they
pick it up something like you know C++
call haskell etc while great languages
have a big learning curve
I think the old slogan batteries
included is still true and what Python
saw something called a glue language so
this is less glamorous but typical Bank
this is kind of like a sister map it
continues continues for quite a bit so
this is like 50 systems there's a lot of
glue you need you to pour some xml file
call a soap service put it all together
send it up on an ftp server and you're
behind the firewall so you can't access
the internet and to get a package
delivered you have to have IT screen it
which takes two weeks so then having a
language where everything is just built
in it just works you can deploy it huge
advantage so just simple work get stuff
done is a big value in a big complicated
organization I think this is a big one
so good
mature libraries for the numerical
scientific I think we already seen
pandas and numpy all over for the
machine learning they actually started
their life for finance so pandas came
from AC or Capital Management so kind of
like a hedge fund that need it is a lot
of time series analysis and that's one
reason it's perfectly well suited it
handles like you know filling missing
data I'll demo that but also handles
like weird stuff like proper business
day handling super boring but if you
actually do something and you're working
against London and New York you only
want to look at the dates that are
business days in both countries so easy
stuff to filter out they are not covered
by like you know your standard date
library so many platforms specialized
ones we talked about like the algo
trading so there's like really good
libraries for doing robotic trading etc
that come from these companies I was
talking about earlier and I've been open
sourced finally really good Excel
handling just being solid on the on the
basics or a big plus speed
I said Python was slow it is but
embedding C++ lets you add speed words
needed
that's why numpy is really fast it's
using you know specialized compiled
things mkl intel library looking on
other platforms i try to do similar
things he likes call and java you kind
of hit it's possible but
things are horrible instead of just
having a prebuilt library that's like
super optimized super fast so as long as
you vectorize things python can stretch
further than you think
talked about embedding already future
here I've seen a lot bots size that
number etc not seen it used live so much
but there's some exciting parts there
about actually being able to write
things in Python and then having it be
really fast so looks super promising
haven't seen it live that much okay not
reassuring this one MLA I of course
super big in finance there's like a
bunch of great use cases I will just say
one thing that this explaining why model
does something is extra important in
finance it's very very Compliance have a
very very regulated so if you say no to
somebody about a loan and there's any
risk that your AI is doing this because
of gender or race or something huge
problem so grab me at a break if you
want to talk about it but of course this
is a big area where Python has a big
lift from being strong in the ml space
and then so this isn't totally one side
it's a why not Python Python the speed
we mentioned talent pool it is actually
a smaller community so big you know huge
thing we're gonna rewrite our core
banking system we need to hire 300
developers we can get it the Java army
in or the consultants can serve us like
hundreds of Java developers or or we
sure we can staff it with that many
senior Python back-end developers so I
would say this is a breaking factor
right now we're stopping factor I've
been on advisory boards for startups
where people plainly said don't even try
it go for node instead or something else
because it's hard to hire people so but
here talking about big companies so the
more people will get the better it's
gonna be there long term some ports like
portal banking is like these really big
enterprise applications I think you
basically need static typing Jeff like
hundreds of people working on something
huge him business-critical I haven't
seen anybody build that kind of thing in
Python not saying it can't be done but
you would need super talented people so
when you need to build something super
big and complicated you tend to reach
for you know Java or something
which is well known and supported for
like big big project development may
change in the future okay that was the
basic slides now and I want to do an
example so you probably heard like do
and put all your eggs in one basket or
like if you buy stocks you shouldn't buy
just one you should buy several who's
kind of heard that kind of advice yes
good so let's have fun then you can try
that out yourself a [ __ ] so what I've
set up is typical example
so using Jupiter notebook want to
highlight a couple of things here
normal ports importing data okay first
one when you do this you need data so
luckily there's a really good library
called it's part of the pandas pandas
data reader this connects automatically
to like a bunch of standard sources boom
load Apple data what did I get
asking for data for Apple and like the
stock price I actually got a lot of
things here and this is kind of welcome
to finance you have opening price
closing price high low for each day some
other stuff over here cool adjusted well
we'll get into that and then of course I
can get one of them and plot it you all
let's check your data so looks great I
have Apple there's the price let's look
at another one it's all do you visa for
bit further back see a huge jump so
what's happened here any guesses yeah it
stock splits so some chance when the
stock price gets too high the company
decides we want to make a cheaper for
people to buy we'll divide the price by
seven and give everybody seven times
their stocks so this will I kill your
data analysis you're doing some
prediction a Sunday the price drops by
seven so of course there's like people
that clean this and you're actually
getting that data for free from these
open sources so it's called adjusted
price so then somebody back calculus is
fills the old data and you have a like
continuous series you can use for
analysis by the way how many people here
own stocks
or trade stocks in any way awesome
utility function to just load this data
cache it give me the close price not
super interesting now let's look at a
basket so I'll take three checkers build
a data frame from them boom so not super
useful I'm looking at like three big
tech stocks here just books they're
familiar names and of course I want to
look at the kind of relative changes
instead so with pandas it's all
vectorized in order to take this and
have all these start at one and just
show me the relative change
it's a one-liner I take the historical
price divided by the first row of the
prices that's exactly what I want so now
I can see how they performed in 2017
which was like a great year to invest
Google was actually doing worst of them
there so let's say my strategy is I will
buy an equal amount of each stock just
to keep it simple in practice I would do
this like weighted you do various
percentages to figure out what the
optimal mix is but let's just say I'll
go 33% of each one then take the returns
sum them up create a new column divide
by the number of stocks and there is a
glitch so what the hell is happening
here there's like a huge spike there in
my portfolio looks strange and I can see
there's a little gap in Apple there so
some kind of price is missing this is
like super typical for Finance welcome
to your day job so you're getting data
from all these vendors and you know
there's a flooding or the stock exchange
wasn't open or something happened with
this company and the price is missing so
always like check your data so pandas
again has really good stuff just okay I
want to feel all missing data I'll just
back village I could interpolate or
whatever all built in so for like an
analyst this makes life so much easier
boom now we've clean data if I hadn't
done that actually with all values here
when I asked to mate the risk for them
I'd be off by a factor four so one
missing data point will tell me my
portfolio is three times riskier if I
hadn't fixed that so what I'm doing here
is I'm calculating volatility that's a
measure of
risky a stock report Foley is to do that
I need to calculate the standard
deviation of the log normal returns
which sounds horrible but because with
pandas it's very close to like math I
can basically write log off returns
percentage change boom and then I can
see my expected result that the
volatility for Apple Facebook Google or
1717 fifteen percent my portfolio is 14
so yes by mixing the stocks I get a
lower volatility great and you can see
that intuitively on the chart like the
red line here which is my portfolio same
kind of general movement but the jumps
are smaller so it's kind of safe for
investment okay then of course I want to
store I'm not happy maybe why these
three stocks maybe I have a couple of
favorites but I can't buy all of them so
I want to kind of play around with it
then I feature a love in here it's like
interact so I can build a simple
function this function here basically
just grabs a couple of symbols just
exactly what I did before and plots this
portfolio but will interact in pandas I
get this so like a mini dashboard I
think similar to what plot K was
describing less advanced and built in
but release it just get started with so
now I can see the thick line here is my
portfolio and these other lines I just
made them different color or the same
color or the stocks and here I can
remove them so I can say well what if I
were just by Google
well my portfolio and Eagle if I mix in
IBM I get this kind of thing so really
really simple way to build something
that's interactive where you can explore
and understand different stock
strategies of course this is check all
sorting from one date so that's you know
a little BS of course this year isn't
going to repeat exactly so I should
study many starting dates it's called
back adjusting so you take some kind of
strategy in this case the strategy is by
equal amount of stocks and you test it
for different dates so first I can do
that visually I set a starting date here
so it can drag the slider and as I'm
dragging it I'm getting you start dates
and I can manually scan this and see who
ply here some like in
just in cases or things that look weird
just to build an intuitive understanding
of how my strategy would behave had I
started on different days finally and
this I'll skip through a little bit I
can do something more statistically
sound so typically once you have your
first thing you'll do a deeper study so
I will look at the stocks are they
really correlate how they're connected
returns and then here I'll do a proper I
think I said in talk like Monte Carlo
simulation so picking random days
combining them to get a statistical
equivalent simulation this is one way of
doing it so basically I'm picking random
days from the past history like several
years history saying that it's probably
going to be similar but not exactly the
same and now we're getting heaviest he's
doing this for a thousand times 60
samples so 60,000 samples boom very fast
books it's all like vectorized c++ and
then you can even plot this so now this
takes a bit more books okay it's a lot
of lines what you're going to see is a
chart showing a thousand different
simulations of what this kind of mix
stock portfolio would look like so
getting into the yeah here we go boom
boom and this is what you would expect
so we're starting at one like you know
same value general it's going upwards we
have some real extreme outliers so hey I
could lose you know 15% a year I could
gain 25% here extreme cases it's a
really good way of Jack's sampling and
seeing what the extremes are and then of
course presenting it as quantile so I'm
saying like hey if I do this strategy if
kind of the stocks have similar
volatility so like a lot of ifs here but
it's this is kind of the way banks
worked you but with a bit more data then
I can be 95% certain of being in this
span and my probable outcome is 7%
return which is like pretty okay for
this period so that's it for the sample
point I want to get across is if you
just want to play around you can it's
all pandas
grab the data from the standard sources
there's like a channel of tutorials when
I post the slides I'll put some good
links in there and if you like you get
this orange letter from the government
saying like your pension is gonna be
worth this much then you can just double
check that do you like your own pension
assessment or stock trading so before
the cure wrap up finance is really big
18 percent of the economy
it's python is like used pretty much
everywhere there so as a developer there
you have a extra good opportunity in as
a business these are probably lucrative
customers if you're doing anything with
like data compliance etc partha success
it's been like fast learn great
libraries and now ml is just giving it
an extra boost and if you think it's
interesting spend some time on it and
just if you learn something and you can
ask better questions
the next time bank the bank tells you to
invest in a particular fund go for it we
are oh yeah I have to add that we're not
hiring books for a small startup so
currently we're fully staffed but if you
kind of like our mission and helping
everybody manage their finances better
talk to me and you know we're probably
expanding next year that's it thank you
Wow we have our first question already
hey thanks for the presentation so I
remember you raised some concerns
regarding the static typing situation
with Python I mean recently they started
having some efforts in new things like
Mike Meyer and adding some further
static checking and like last time I
checked and I actually used it it is it
is evolving quite well but I wanted to
ask in your experiences if you have seen
it on the wild or how you see it yes I
have not and in general I've seen people
who work in these places or like super
business focused super busy so they
often don't have the time to do like you
know the really deep dives and
innovations in setting up the latest
news the infrastructure they'll just
grab it use it and kind of solve a real
problem so probably not leading edge
there but I do see that as like the
long-term solution like once you're
seeing the Python it's all over anyway
then if they can get it stable or like
stabilized with something like that
maybe you can bake this build these
monster applications on it
and they're really I'm talking about
like you know the army of like 200
consultants all working together and
huge builds that kind of environment so
any more questions
hello like finance is really like
delicate like regarding to if I make a
mistake then a lot of people are going
to be very angry like how do you handle
like human mistakes like how do they
handle finance yeah that's actually a
very interesting question because you're
right like kind of the places I work
like if some price feed goes down you
don't detect it you're losing a hundred
thousand dollars like them folk
somebody's going to see your mistake and
they're gonna trade on it I the kind of
answer is I guess very carefully and
knowing what what's important like
you're doing some kind of internal
report she can go really fast like you
know we're quickly you're doing
something that modifies the prices
you're quoting to the market you know
it's super dangerous you get a lot of
people to check it it's having a very
good feeling for when to go fast and
when to just be very slow and very
careful and then an enormous amount of
monitoring also having manual people in
the check yeah in the loop so often
we're dragged one project we did like a
go live and we had new products going
out and I think we're all set human-made
office like a third of the deals had to
be backed out but it was a person
manually checking things before they
went out and you're in the goal I period
they could do that and then once you
scale up you remove the manual person so
that's one definitely way last question
thank you and I would like to ask you in
combination with Python what would be
the second element that you would
suggest someone to study if they want to
get deeper into the fine tech field
right right that depends on the area if
you're going for like the hedge funds
high-frequency trading
C++ that kind of thing if you're going
for like you know just more operations
like being really good at Excel can
actually be good I mean it's used so
much that if you have like you know
superpowers there
it's really good but it totally depends
on where you're going but for the
hardcore stuff C++ maybe Scala Java is a
good compliment okay that was it for the
questions yep thanks yes
[Applause]